very good thank you very much so it's my
pleasure to introduce our next speaker
Alexander kapoor ashima he works as a
data scientist at pivotal and he's going
to be talking to us about a data science
operationalization framework and I
believe it has something to do with open
source as well is that right it does
okay it's on github very good
yeah thanks Valentin so yeah my name is
Alex Kagoshima I work as a data
scientist at pivotal as Valentin said
and what pivotal does is on the one side
we have a couple of big data platforms
we have a open source pass platform for
deploying applications and the third
thing we do is kind of app development
and data science which is also the part
of the company I am in and what I do as
a data scientist at pivotal is I don't
work on pivotal internal data I have
customers who buy our Big Data Platform
to kind of realize use cases to to
gather value out of their data they put
their data on our platform which we put
on their premises and then I go in and
develop some models on top of it that
then show what we can basically do with
big data so that is that is my job and
so I put PowerPoint in this view because
otherwise the the ends they get cut off
so what we do in our engagements one big
thing that might not be typical for all
data scientists but it's definitely
definitely true for data scientists
which kind of work on one one-off
project kind of limited projects at one
customer is that we often go into a
customer and the customer has really a
lot of data sources here's like a dozen
Oracle databases and there's an S AP
system that uses that as a back-end this
I don't know
MySQL there's post quest is loads of
siloed data sources we work mostly with
enterprise customers so
that's especially true if you have a
company with I don't know 200,000
employees and they also have siloed
systems and they can have kind of have
this very very complicated landscape
where they run their business off and
it's to me it's often a miracle that
this works but apparently it does and
when we go in we we say okay what do you
want to do okay you want to I don't know
limit you want to analyze the GPS data
that your fleet is collecting or
something then we say okay we need all
your GPS data then we do this big data
extract and we pull all of that and put
it in some kind of distributed big data
platform which nowadays is mostly Hadoop
could also be something different and
within the distributed big data platform
we or I do my job I work on the data
extract I develop models on top of it
analyzing all this historical data
gathering intelligence out of it and
then my model it really it lives here
but I then also do is I create some kind
of oh that's not good I create a fancy
PowerPoint mostly showing the results of
my model showing what it can do to the
business and that's I don't want to say
that's it but in reality it is mostly so
we we also often say models go to
PowerPoint to die so so the model really
lives here and it's if we if we're
really honest to ourselves it's a bunch
of scripts it's not a really cool
application that is easily you did
someone else can run you usually need
the guy who coded it to run the to run
the model and that's that's not good
because if we when we have that
situation the big question is how do we
come back here how do we do this
because the business is run of this
landscape right so all the business
decision that I don't know the Excel
reporting sheets that the manager sees
they are pulled from these systems and
having all of this heared and nobody
really can do anything with the stuff we
did the interesting thing is also if you
look at all the big data frameworks for
for analyzing data spark or flink for
example or I don't know what Map Reduce
two years ago they they're really good
at solving the problem here so they're
really good at taking a big amount of
data and then extracting something out
of it they're really good at doing all
of that here but there's no real
principled way of getting the results
back here so I think this is a this is a
really big problem that we as data
scientists we really should work on so
otherwise we are stuck in the hype cycle
and then everybody will say no data
scientists we can't deliver so we really
in my mind as data scientists we really
need to work on being better at
transporting our models to the business
yes so these are the points that are
already mentioned so we have really
scripting instead of production-ready
models if you look at me I I have like a
dozen ipython notebooks and then I
create some scripts out of it and then I
know the order of the scripts which
which they should be running then I put
numbers in front of the scripts to make
it look easy but in reality it's not so
that means if I if I want to hand that
over I really need to train the people
and I don't know if they remember what I
what I told them it's it's really not
it's really not a reliable way in my
mind it also takes pretty long to to
actually get this platform up and
running so that's especially true in our
case because when we work with
enterprise customers would we tell them
or what they want is they really want
something on
so something like Amazon or something
where they need to put their data
outside of their premises they don't
want to do that so that is especially
true to us long setup times it's bad to
encapsulate our work for others to reuse
and operationalization how how do you
actually do this so what do we need to
to actually try it differently so what
we really want to have is an easy way to
actually operationalize models to to
kind of attach our models to existing
legacy systems which which would really
need to be some kind of interface right
some kind of API when when we as data
scientist when we do our modeling it's
also often the case that we we might
choose the more fancy algorithm that is
really mathematically elegant and maybe
not the simple one that just gets the
job done right and maybe the simple one
in my experience is often easier easier
to operationalize so I think as data
scientists we really need to start to
think about operationalization from the
beginning and so what I did in in this
special case is I leveraged Cloud
Foundry which is our open-source pass to
to spin up environments quickly but I
will get into that more later so what I
did
having all of these problems in mind and
wanting to do something about this is I
created a small operationalization
framework as I call it so you can think
about it as exposing an API so it uses
flask to do that basically so I have
some routes some routes defined in flask
where you can kind of ingest data so you
can send data to that framework as Jason
and
it sends results back as a Jason what I
do what I did just to get running
quickly is use Redis as a model and
storage back-end so whenever I create a
model within this framework it it all
gets stored into Redis and also the data
gets stored into Redis which is to be
honest it's not really scalable yet so
it's Redis is very fast which is good
but it's not really made for for big
amounts of data so what you would
actually want to have is a true big data
store like Hadoop I implemented two
models just to show how it works
linear regression and online linear
regression and the cool thing is so it's
deployable to Cloud Foundry so about a
family who knows what Heroku is okay so
you can think of Cloud Foundry as Heroku
but you can set up your own hero cou
okay
Heroku just has one instance that sits
somewhere in the cloud where you then
push your apps - but Cloud Foundry means
you can set up your own paths on your
own cluster ok and then you can use that
which is really cool for enterprises
because again enterprises they're
paranoid they don't want to use the
cloud especially in Germany so they
really like this it's open-source you
can check out the website and this is
kind of the Heroku instance of cloud for
me ok here you can sign up and then you
can push applications there and the
framework that I'm going to show you in
a second is actually also deployed there
yes so it's it's basically it's the idea
of a path so you can push applications
there and and make them run there
quickly and leave all of the hassle with
database setup and so on aside
so this is actually what what the
framework looks like a so I so from this
you can probably understand a little bit
better what I'm what I'm talking about
all the time so you have this API which
you can talk to you send JSON there so
you send a JSON request it says create
me a model and what it does then
somewhere here in the backend it creates
a model and stores that in Redis and
then you can say okay send data to that
model as a jason then the api will
ingest the data and kick off a
retraining so a periodic retraining
probably because usually not on every
data point you need to have some kind of
retraining right but it does this
automatically so you just start sending
it data and then it kicks off the
retraining and then saves off to saves
the model into Redis and there's also
some visualization thing which I did
which I will also show you in a little
bit so it's actually deployed here so if
you go here you come on to the landing
page which is just the readme markdown
that that you also see on github so if
you want to get the code it's here and
the the idea of this is really to have
some kind of encapsulated model so you
don't have a model any anymore that is
basically a bunch of scripts that sit
somewhere on a big data platform and
it's really hard to to operationalize
this is really an API that makes it easy
to attach other parts of software to it
and with this I think we can do some
demoing oh that's really hard to read
read
so wait and so here did that's Redis
Redis is awesome by the way
you just install it say reddit server
and boom it's there it's really cool
this is where I start the framework so
I'm running it now locally but you can
just push it to Heroku or Cloud Foundry
and then it will run there the same way
and what I'm going to do now a good idea
might be to first go onto the web page
just to show you what it looks like so
this is basically what you see when you
get there first and it kind of tells you
how to operate it so to create a model
and it's really hard to read I guess to
create a model you do this curl request
and this is the actual data that you
that you're sending so you say okay this
model has a name you specify a type of
the model which you would need to
implement before and then you give it
this retrain counter which says okay
every every ten new data points I
actually want to do some retraining so
let's create a model of this kind so
here I'm sending it to JSON request how
do I make this font bigger
and that works so once I send it this
request it says created model can you
read that even bigger come on you can
read that
so that says created model retrain
counter available data it's not trained
it's the model of this kind it doesn't
have any training data that is used and
it's called model one sorry I have no
idea what you're talking about
oh oh I'm sorry about that I'm not doing
that
just come to me later I will show you so
what what was I doing now so so now we
have created the model what we want to
do now is send it data and it's maybe
take a look at it here first so the way
that you send the data this is also the
the way you send it with curl and this
is the this is the data that you're
sending so this is a Jason okay so you
ascended the model name and so instead
of calling it X and y I just called it
input and labels so label is always the
thing that is the model kind of that's
the dependent variable that the model
needs to learn and this is the input so
if if you look at this input and label
thing so and you know it's linear
regression what kind of function is
learning y equals x exactly know f of x
equals y yeah
okay so we we are going to send that
data into the model then oh there's
another thing I can show so basically
what you can also do is you can go to
models and here so this is a really
basic view so you have a set so you have
this model one and you then you can also
go into model one and then it tells you
the current state of the model but now
let's send some data into the model okay
so here it's ten it's nine it's eight so
we we sent ten data points into the
model and then if we go to this view
again then you can see okay it's it's
train now since we'd sent ten data
points in and the parameters it learned
are input one for input and it has a
zero constant so it learned to read
function okay so that's basically the
the very basic view of what it can do
which is not really exciting so I
created a visualization that looks a
little bit better
so what I'm doing here is this is some
simulator that sends data into the model
all the time and I can visualize this
like this so what you see here is the
last hundred data points that were sent
in and you can see always new data
points coming in and the data points are
generated by by this by basically a
linear function with some noise added to
it and then the the blue line that is
wiggling around that is that is the
trained model that it's learning so but
what can happen if you were training a
model is it can happen that the behavior
changes to be the underlying behavior so
that's what I'm doing here so basically
you can see the the the underlying data
that that the model sees is changing and
you can see the model adapting to that
so this is the online linear regression
part of it so this is a this is a really
really basic example I know but this is
this was I actually really like this
visualization I showed this to a couple
non-technical people and they were very
unimpressed they said what is this this
just points and this is a line it
Wiggles around and it doesn't tell them
anything but I think if you know some
stuff about machine learning so it's a
model and it learns something okay this
is this is something that's cool yeah so
that's basically all this is doing okay
and the other cool part of it is also
that you can deploy it on a path
so yeah once you have this is this this
API it provides a simple way to to
expose it to other parts of software you
can could think about if you have a web
application you could send some stream
to a framework like this and and you
need some kind of prediction and then it
sends sends you some some data back what
you could also do with a framework like
this as a data scientist is some tedious
work you have to do so if you if you're
working on a problem and you have this
data set and you create different kinds
of features and you have different kinds
of models then what you actually need to
do is you really need to keep track of
everything you're doing right you need
to keep track of all the different
feature engineering variants of all the
different model variants that you have
and you need to keep track of all the
results so you know at the end what what
was the best thing you did and you could
think about integrating some
visualization they are there that you
can access by the browser which then
tells you which keeps track of
everything for you
so you could use something like this to
to free yourself of really tedious work
just focus on the feature engineering
and the modeling you could also think
about creating different model instances
via the API let's say you have different
classes of data in your in your stream
you and you can you can easily use
standard machine learning models that
you have and once you created the model
with this it's really easy to reuse but
the requirement is really you need a
live feed of the data which at least for
us as kind of consulting data scientists
is a little bit hard to get but we are
getting there this is also really hard
to read right
so this is showing how you would
implement a model so this is the linear
regression model and what you can see
here is that it implements a model
interface and that model interface tells
the tell tells you that you need to
implement these three functions range
score and parameters so all you need to
do if you want to create a new model
within this framework is implement a
class like this and if you want to look
at the code this is the github address
so if you want to expand the model like
this I think you could actually expand a
framework like this to actually work in
this enterprise landscape you have this
basic API where some stuff happens in
the backend you would you would need
some additional modules like a data
ingest module for example that maybe
there's some pre-processing you would
probably need something like a cleaning
and the transformation module that mmm
helps you to also to pre-process the
data and maybe aggregate the data a
little bit and what you would also need
is a proper big data store right now
it's storing everything in Redis which
is as I said not really scalable and so
one cool thing about pass is that you
could also think about getting some kind
of data exploration module in there so
think about what we do as data scientist
so oftentimes we get the data on our
onto our local machine and on our local
machine we really have a bunch of tools
we have I don't know upon us on there so
I could learn my plot lib and then we do
our stuff there and then it sometimes
happens oh I need this thing as
and you need to install it first and so
on but what about if you had this image
set up for you this container that
already contains all of this and if you
do you work you just lock onto this this
container or machine that is hooked up
here and then you already have
everything in here and then you can
access the the data so this is just some
wide idea that I have and another
important part is that what you also
usually have you usually don't start
from a green field where you have no
data at all usually you have to speak
data extra to orderly and you would also
need something that doesn't only receive
data but also receive a data reference
so something that says okay the data
sits in Hadoop in this path and it's of
this file format so this is something
that you would need to work towards if
you really want to use that in an
enterprise environment so then this is
just really a tiny thing that I put
together in a few days based on my
observations that I that I gathered
during my work and there's really a
couple of open questions that you need
to answer before you use for word for
example does it make sense to have the
training and the scoring on the same
machine or would it make more sense to
split that out and have one thing that
only does the training and one thing
that only does the scoring if you if you
want to be really scalable it this would
probably need to happen the the ability
that you can actually push that thing
onto a pass gives you immediate access
to automatic scaling so let's say you
have you your website suddenly gets ten
times more users you just scale the the
containers that you put there up but how
and how exactly that this users kind of
open you could also spin a multiple
instances
then there's the question that I
mentioned about feature transformation
and feature engineering also is it
possible to use the same data
transformation process on the incoming
streaming data and on the end on the
training data that's already there
there's also the case where you have
feature and generators that only work in
batches where you need to aggregate some
data that also wouldn't work with this
kind of framework but would would be
something that you would need to think
about and if if you actually send
scoring data to that framework all the
time you would also need a way to add a
label to that data data probably so
there's really still this is this is
just a tiny little prototype framework
that I didn't just these lots of open
question that that put that you would
need to answer if you want to move this
forward so I am NOT the first one who
thought about this there's a couple of
similar stuff which is very interesting
so there's Velox which is it seems like
it's in very infant stages but it's from
the amp those are the guys who developed
spark there's the Google prediction API
and there's prediction i/o so prediction
i/o I would say it's the most similar
thing to what I did if you use something
like the Google prediction API you're
basically stuck with Google so Google
then eats up all your data and you can
only do it on Google's premises so if
you have some framework like this you
can also deploy it on your own premises
right which is not the case with Google
okay so with these pointers and
basically none and open for any
questions
the audience just a real-life example of
know what you did and where this could
be an applicable model maybe for the
next time you do it again so one
interesting data science engagement that
I worked on recently was detecting
malware communication within proxy locks
and one of the models we created was
just analyzing the domain name so
there's more where which communicates to
these randomly generated strings and
that's a use case way you could
perfectly use this kind of framework
because all that you need is you send
and these frame these these domain names
all the time and then you would get a
score back so this is a real because
this is such a simple model it just
scores one domain name based on some
natural language processing you could
you could actually do it in this kind of
in this version of the framework but
that being said for a lot of more
complicated use cases where you need to
aggregate the data first in some way
then it would you would need to do some
more work any more questions hi in the
API example I saw that you were sending
your example like in the label directly
to a model so wouldn't it make sense
like to decouple this because typically
when you do this you use the data with
many different models especially when
you do exploration so I think like
having a data like entity and the models
and then basically what you're
interested in is applying this part of
data to that particular model so there's
like a many-to-many relationship here in
the end yeah yeah definitely you you
could you could do that I invite you to
pull the code from github and do do that
no but that's a that's a cool idea
perhaps time for one more question
all right if there is no more questions
let's thank the speaker once again thank
you
you